[Music]
all day
[Music]
hi y'all and welcome to mooco's corner
mooco's corner is a show about leading a
life that feels more you in your life
and tech career i'm your host mayuko and
i invite you to come on sit down get a
tea or something like that maybe today
get cozy and enjoy the show
today's guest we have tom from the
channel bite review tom is a youtuber
making really aesthetic videos about
gadgets gear and desk setup videos on
youtube with the background in teaching
he also works as a photographer and
videographer on a freelance basis and
it's based in the uk if you can't tell
from his accent already so hi tom how
are you doing how's your week though
hello yeah very good thank you um i'm
trying to think of all the exciting
things you've done yeah it's funny you
say accent because like i'd it's i think
it must be an english thing but i don't
feel like i have an accent and then when
everyone's like oh your accent's so
english i'm like is it this is just
this is just so like normal to me
you know i don't know it's subjective
you like i mean
to you i have an accent right like i
have the american probably californian
accent yeah
but yours is cool mine's so dull
mine's just so basic yours is cool i
mean i think it's probably grass on the
ground but i always thought british
accents sound super cool
uh i'll do my best to speak
the queens today then
i also like the local accents too i you
know i i watch like um fair amount of
like british television and then they
always say like oh this is like a very
like scouse accents very like south
london accent i'm just like i don't know
what any of that means but i'm gonna
learn i guess because there's they're so
different
there's so many as well and some of them
honestly are horrid like they're really
hot it's like oh
but some of them are really lovely
there's a fair few it's funny because
where i'm from down in the southwest
there there isn't like uh
there isn't an accent if there's a
standard
english accent i guess that's the one i
have there's no like point to it or
anything because they they often think
we're from like farmer country because
that's where all the farms are down here
so everyone's a bit like like uar and
all that sort of stuff when you talk
about farms and but yeah it's oh it's
what it is do you have any like do you
have any like words that you use in your
area but not others that are like local
vocabulary um
probably the only one that springs to
mind would be like saying um matey
instead of like so if you don't know who
you're talking about it's like oh maybe
up the road said this or oh matey at the
shop said that
that
that's an interesting southwest sort of
thing um or saying versus like what do
you usually say like or not usually but
what are people in other parts of the uk
i guess you'd just say that person or
whoever
or something but you yeah it's just like
a if you don't know their name they're
matey
interesting that's like that's like my
dude where i was like dude up the road
said that like you said this
there is commonality between where you
are and where i am and that we both live
in like seaside towns uh we learned that
last time we chatted so maybe that's the
thing maybe we want to see side down you
have a name for like
that guy
matey or dude
i think you use the the sound or you use
the the coast much more than i do i
literally live like 10 minutes away from
a beach maybe less and um i don't use it
at all i don't go surfing i don't go to
the beach it's dreadful i should is that
like i don't know you do people in your
area like okay so my this is like i
apologize if i'm stereotyping a little
bit but like my image of the beaches in
the uk are like cold so like it's not
you don't enjoy it in the same way that
we enjoy it here in california that's
very true
it's usually raining as well
[Laughter]
right so like are there people in your
town who do like
watery things and if so what what do
they do like what sports or what
activities it's it's all always surfing
like it's probably one of the biggest
things okay down here is surfing it's
the main one like
i i like to say i live close to a beach
but there's when i say a beach i mean
there's probably about five beaches
within a 15 minute radius like wow
there's a big there's a big surf
community around it and all that sort of
thing a few mates that live over the
road for me love it and they go very
often but it literally like it almost
closes for the winter because it's so
cold here so it'll just like they'll be
like i've got winter suits on until
october and then we'll just stop until
may or something oh my i mean i bet the
wetsuits are like so thick i watched
this um surf documentary once where like
this guy
i i think he was he was just trying to
like surf at the most amount of beaches
as possible within a short period of
time so he just like bought a van like i
think he started in scotland and then he
decided to make his way down europe or
something like that
and like it looked so cold and he had
like a thick wetsuit with the hood and
everything and i was just like
oh my like i feel like my heart would
stop getting into you see a lot of
people here that have got the the hood
the gloves the boots
yeah everything
yeah i bet you i mean i feel cold in my
water and i'm just wearing like a
regular wetsuit and i've started to
think about like maybe i should get
booties but like i can't even imagine
the waters up there like san francisco
when i lived there i was like there's no
way i'm going swimming in san francisco
and the uk is even further north than
that i probably sound really ignorant
right now and i'm sorry
we're learning
we are we're learning about our
different parts of the world because we
are like
hundreds of thousands of miles away
but yeah okay cool this it's very
interesting to
talk to someone from a different part of
the world always okay so i guess like
backstory the way that i met tom i guess
and the way that we know each other is i
found i'm also related to death set up
as you all know from my youtube channel
so i get a lot of like desk setup
related content recommended to me on
youtube and instagram i found this
instagram post with this really cool
digital background like wallpaper
and it was tagged with bite review and i
was like what is this wallpaper i need
it right now
and so that i found tom through that
because he sells his digital walkers
through his store kiroku and then i
started following you on like youtube
and instagram and stuff and then you
were just like oh hey and then i was
just like
oh my gosh
he's like
we're gonna be friends because genuinely
your content and like your death setups
are so beautiful like there's like i
wish i had found your stuff so much
earlier because um you know the way that
i try to do my desk setup is very we've
talked about this not rgb like very like
organic like comforting light like
bright natural light um and like
surrounding yourself with like things
that you love sort of things like it's
just not the gamer setup
that look is just horrible well yeah
like thank you so much for the kind
words it does mean a lot especially
coming from
yourself but um
yeah one of the
i guess yeah like you said i absolutely
hate that that kind of gamer aesthetic
where it's all like rgb and like it
looks like you're in some sort of a
cyberpunk neon
like
wonderland like yeah i can get i can see
i can kind of see why people like it but
the second you show me a gaming chair
like i want to throw up it's like
horrible
but like yeah so basically when when
i've been like making my setups and
stuff i always thought quite hard about
what
what do i actually want because it's so
easy to like look at some posts and be
like i'm just going to copy that because
that i think is the right look and you
don't actually like really think about
what you want so like i just wanted the
opposite of a gamer aesthetics i just
wanted it to be like
super clean but also full of color and
vibrancy and like you know a couple
plants and just make it like really make
it my own because
it's even even when you like avoid the
gamer stuff it's really easy to go down
that kind of clinical look where it's
almost like just gray white black which
i i like that look i really do like that
look when i see it i'm like oh yeah it's
great but it's not it's not personal and
that's kind of like one of the things i
really pushed i was like oh i like all
this like japanese inspired stuff and i
really like nintendo and i really like
uh clean pine wood and all that sort of
stuff and i'm gonna put in all the
colors i like because why not
so that's kind of like where it all came
from
yeah and i told you this last time but
one of my favorite things about your
videos is that you always have a jubilee
movie playing on the background so it's
just like it's not only like your death
setup but it also really comes alive in
your content too and like creating that
very like
this is this is tom he's really
interested in all these things also i
relate to a lot of it i was looking at
your youtube channel the other day and i
was just like these thumbnails are just
so pretty i don't want to click on all
of them and watch oh because i know all
of them are going to be so good so uh
you know i don't know how much of an
overlap we have between our audiences
but like just to kind of like intro
you a little bit further can you tell
everybody like how did you like get into
making youtube content and like how you
got started all that kind of stuff
yeah sure really long story something to
really crush it down basically i was a
tutor at a local college which is
someone that helps like students apply
to go to university through ucas which
is what we have in the uk and that was
for the most stressful job i had in my
life had like 300 students they all had
to apply and
students have wide range of issues some
of them are lovely and some of them are
really tricky to work with and some of
them have problems that you just can't
comprehend so i
handed my notice halfway through that
year and then at the end of the year i
just pulled out because i didn't want to
do it anymore but i didn't want to be
that kind of teacher that leaves like
you know midway like oh we had this guy
and then we had that person and so i i
was like i'll stick it out just for that
year just so they have at least some
sort of consistent experience um so i
left and then the same college had a um
opening for a media technician which is
like help the students give them cameras
all that sort of stuff um and i hadn't
touched a camera at this point i was 25
and i've not touched you know not been
anywhere near it i thought apply for it
and then it was part time and i can just
find something else anyway i ended up
really loving it
picked up my own camera and then because
i've been watching like the i'd say the
golden oldies of youtube so like your
home kbhd and you know all the originals
like i was like oh if i'm going to learn
to use this camera and show the students
i at least need to
prove like do it so i just started
making videos about phones and all that
sort of stuff
and then while i was doing that
the teachers noticed that i was quite
good at you know editing video and using
photoshop mainly and they're like hey
teach the teach the students um a little
bit each week if you like you know two
hours a week i think it started out and
then the next year they're like do you
want to do it seven hours a week because
it's a bit more money as well which
obviously was good and then i ended up
going a full-time media teacher which
was cool for a couple years
and i was still doing youtube and all
this time i was doing youtube in my
lunch breaks i i lived really close so i
could run back home film for like this
is how like mad it was at the time i'd
run home and film for like half an hour
and come back to college
and teach for the rest of the time
yeah which which is good because it
shows i i really enjoyed it obviously um
but it was you know it was a lot and
then um
basically uh
i was making an uh you know
not i'm not going to say loads from
youtube because it wasn't it was it was
low amount but it was enough to drop
like a day maybe so i said i want to go
part-time if that's okay cause i kind of
want to follow this so they they ended
up just pushing all my teaching hours
into three days rather than five and so
i just got really like overworked and
stuff and then covered hit and i was
like i ain't doing this anymore it's
critic it's like absolutely crazy i got
another job with a marketing company um
as a freelancer which i still work for
them a little bit at the moment um two
days a week and then i just decided i'm
gonna give youtube a go for three days a
week and then
here i am
yes
[Laughter]
love that background that's really cool
it's awesome that you started in
teaching and then now because i think
they're like no matter what kind of
youtube content you're creating you are
still
teaching in some way like literally even
if it's just telling a story yeah
definitely and so that's awesome that
like you have that background and you've
been able to kind of like use those
skills i've actually seen some of your
like photography and videography content
too which is like so good i was i was
like looking at your website yesterday i
was just like how the heck did he like
this like i don't know so so you're so
talented in all these different ways and
i'm like i admire your work so much okay
so kind of going back to sort of like
gadgets and stuff right because like i
talk about it sometimes on my channel
but it's not really mean
i mean it is kind of one of the main
focuses now that i'm getting really into
it like learning about all these
different keyboards and monitors and
stuff like that but the rabbit
the rabbit hole literally like you can
go so deep right so like
when you're like you know testing out
content or you're testing out gadgets
you're creating content like how do you
how do you decide like what's like the
best gadget right especially because you
know my audience is in technology and
it's just like well you need x y and z
to have like the perfect setup to do
programming to do video editing to do
whatever right and like there's just so
many options out there so like how do
you how do you mentally like think about
all that in terms of like just all the
options out there
like what's the best for you and like
it's
also so tempting right because you see
all these nice things on youtube and
you're like oh i could probably use that
and then you yeah
yeah don't buy it and don't i know i've
fallen into that trap like many times
but i guess i guess you kind of fall
into like two camps and the the first
camp is one i always try and stick to is
like what what do you actually like what
do you actually need like
so this is one of the reasons why i've
kind of like rece well like the last
year in my youtube channel i've just
like veered to apple products like
pretty much iphone and
mac and all that sort of stuff i just
like finally made the big switch from my
pc to the mac studio and that's been a
long process um because it just makes my
life easier and this is one of the
reasons i stopped looking at android
phones is because every time i switch to
it everything around that would become a
lot harder so like my immediate family
use an iphone or my friends use an
iphone like you know my girlfriend uses
an iphone says it's so easy for us to
just communicate and at the end of the
day that's what the phone is for is for
communicating so as soon as like as a
barrier even if it is quite small like
in the uk we use whatsapp like pretty
much 90 of the time but for those like
five percent of the times when
i can't get in contact or like
kelly would text me like why aren't you
picking up facetime it's like i don't
have it right now it's just those little
things so
the perfect gadget really is the one
that kind of
really fits your lifestyle but then
you've also got to ignore everyone else
saying like oh you know they're rubbish
why'd you have that it's like i don't
care like that's the one that works for
me but i also think there's a second
camp because there is a second camp and
i've been there i've jumped in and out
of it and i recently hopefully think i
jumped out of it is that kind of like i
think they call it gas or like gear
acquisition syndrome where you like
constantly thinking what can i get next
what can i get next and like i had that
with cameras like i bought a fuji camera
and i really loved it and i had this
like you know vision of me using it when
we go traveling and like taking all
these amazing shots of this amazing fuji
camera and i realized at the end of the
day i'd just fallen into this trap of
like really wanting it because i want
the thing but not actually like what it
produces and then when i got it i was a
bit like oh you know what actually your
autofocus isn't quite where i wanted it
and then i just kept going back to my
sony and i was like this this wasn't
right for me so
yeah i think those are the two things so
yeah if trying to pick the perfect
gadget is trying as hard as it is try
and zone out everybody else and just
think what do you actually want right
right right
yeah i feel like if you
if you know what those things are then
you go into like gadget review videos on
youtube because oftentimes like the
first step is to go there which is great
because then you're informed and stuff
like that um but it can be kind of like
decision paralysis too
but i love that it's just like at the
end of the day like technology in my you
know in my opinion technology's supposed
to help your lifestyle it's supposed to
help you do things and if it's getting
in the way then it probably means it's
not
like there's something else better out
there and then gives you a reason to
like go and do those things like i
remember one of the biggest blockers for
me when i was starting youtube was like
i thought i had to have this thousand
dollar camera kind of thing and then
someone was like oh you can just film on
your ipad or your iphone because iphone
cameras were pretty good by then um and
i was just like oh okay and then that
unlocked me to do it but then you know
after you use it for a while like you
start noticing there's these certain
things that get in the way with iphone
where it's just like okay well i can't
offload it to a memory card there's only
certain limitations with like the
quality and like you can't um you know
toggle the aperture as easily and all
that kind of stuff and then it gives you
a reason to like go inside the other
thing you've got to go like you kind of
got to upgrade with like how your skill
set upgrades like and i always used to
say that to students like you don't need
your first video should be shot on your
phone or should be shot on the college
camera because you know
you can't if i gave you my sony you'd
still produce
you know not a great thing it would you
know just feel like you've not done it
quite as well but like that's it that's
why you know i stuck with my um
sony like my first sony camera for like
three and a half years i didn't upgrade
it because i was like i don't think i
need to and then when it got to that
point where it's like do you know what
keeps overheating and it keeps like
filling up the memory card too like
slowly and you know i have to buy these
other memory cards and then i can't buy
this lens for it i can't buy that lens
for it and then suddenly it's like okay
well now it's worth the upgrade
yeah i i it's i feel like yeah whenever
it's hard to give blanket advice to i
think as like creators sometimes to just
be like
this is the one that you need because it
is so case by case and especially on
youtube when it's just like people are
just going to watch your video no matter
what challenge they're encountering kind
of thing but that's also what i like i
really like the way that you framed a
lot of your videos where you were you're
talking about like here are the use
cases in which this gadget could be
useful to you um i hear the ways that i
use it as a way to kind of just like
really like make it more human oriented
um and just really because like at the
end of the day these gadgets are not
like what we're revolving around in our
day-to-day lives they help us do these
things and if like it's kind of like
it's it's silly kind of sometimes you
think about where it's just like
we've had gadgets around for like
decades ish at this point now and we
don't really know how to use them but in
reality like we kind of don't like
sometimes we need that pointer just like
here are
here's this way that you've never
thought about about before and how you
can use this gadget that maybe you have
or you don't have that i feel like
is a really interesting way to like tell
the story of gadgets that i i usually
don't typically see in the gadget space
definitely and like that's that's one of
my favorite kind of videos to make is
like
i think one of the like more popular
videos on my channel is like how to get
the most out of your ipad and it's like
here's actually like seven ways you
probably haven't really thought about
using it which it's really really good
for
and like making those videos are like
usually the funnest because i'll do a
bit of research beforehand as well just
see if there's anything that i've missed
and then sometimes i've like i've
totally missed one and i'm like oh my
god that's incredible i like i've gotta
you know i've gotta use it like there's
this really simple way it's like a three
pinch to like copy and paste
i didn't know about that recently crazy
yeah yeah you can do that across so if
you like grab something from your ipad
you can actually go
straight to your iphone and just pinch
back out and it will just paste it and
it's just like
what why don't they talk about that sort
of thing
totally it's like buried deep in like
one of those sessions at like an apple
talk kind of thing that like most
consumers are not going to go to
and so it is kind of up to like content
creators to kind of like pull those
things out and just be like look at what
you can do with it but it's like and
then even then like when when apple or
some companies are talking about it they
talk about like oh you can do this but
like until we actually apply it to our
lives it can kind of just be like
yeah like so like what what's the point
kind of thing you know definitely i
think one of the biggest things like i
kind of not struggle with but one of the
things i've started mentioning a lot of
my videos now is like
as a as a content creator and i'm sure
you probably have this as well it's like
i don't i don't live in like the general
experience anymore i've like i'm almost
like i've come out of it because because
i test every single ipad because kind of
like my job now
everyone's like oh why have you upgraded
it's like i haven't like i wouldn't if
if i wasn't doing this i wouldn't i
would be i would probably still be using
my ipad pro from 2018 because there's
nothing wrong with that and it still
works fine
but
but like and then i think sometimes when
they see it they're like oh he's
upgraded so i should think about
upgrading it's like no no it's not it's
never that like try and i always think
to always like try and say like if i if
i wasn't doing what i'm doing i'd be on
my ipad pro from 2018 and i'd probably
have like an iphone 11 or something from
a couple years back and i'd be really
happy with it have you made a video like
that before i'm just like if i didn't
here here's like what i would use if i
didn't have to upgrade all the time i've
i haven't but i've literally started
putting it towards the end of every well
the next couple of videos i've said like
i was trying to put myself in a consumer
frame of mind like what would i actually
buy i think i said my ipad air review
like if i was like didn't have an ipad
right now that's what i would go for
because it makes the most sense but it's
so it's so tricky because i've got the
12.9 aperture pro right there i've got
the the mini there and i've got the one
over there so my choice is ridiculous it
is almost stupid
yeah i did it
i think it's just like it's like it
becomes fomo right we're like
i mean i have this ipad and then i'm
just like i have i have yet to even make
an ipad video because i feel like it's
taking about this long to like really be
able to talk about it
because i've been needing to figure out
how to include it into my lifestyle like
naturally i guess
and then i and then yeah sometimes i see
reviews i'm like maybe i should buy the
new ipad and then it's just it's
literally nothing but fomo
yeah it is
yeah and like trying to try i think
trying to force something into your
workflow if it doesn't work after like a
few days then then like dropping it is
fine like if it doesn't fit it doesn't
fit and like i honestly was like that
with ipads for the longest time like i
was like these don't work for me i don't
know why i'd need one but it just slowly
it crap it kind of slowly crept up on me
and it's like oh now i don't leave the
house without it
right
when you realize that something's like
not working for you like do you like
sell it back or like do you
like how like because that's one of the
things that i'm like it's i think it's
for some people it's really easy to get
into that mindset of like oh i can try a
gadget and then just like sell it back
and then
for me i'm always just like but if i try
it then i feel like i've used it and so
i can't give it back or like i'm just
stuck with it like it feels like every
decision that i make in gadgets death
setup is like permanent sometimes yeah
and so then you get
yeah and then i think that's exactly
what causes decision paralysis because
you're just like i have to live with
this forever which is totally not true
no yeah i know i know exactly what you
mean like i think i had that when i i
picked up the new um macbook pro 14-inch
which i had in like december and january
and i i like bought it and i was like so
excited to to use it and all that sort
of thing and then when i started using
it i realized you know what this one
this one's not the right one for me and
i had that weird guilt i was like oh i
can't return it because i've used it for
like a week or like two weeks sorry at
the time
and i was talking to my friend he's like
just return it mate like they won't care
like that's what returns a four like in
uk in the uk at least they're they're
very like i don't know i think i'll uh
the eu oh no we're not part of the eu so
that's how easy it is to forget
that the law for it is very good like
you can pretty much return it for like
a year on amazon it's something
ridiculous so i was like i'm sure jeff
bezos isn't gonna mind so i literally
just returned it but i know what you
mean like i when i was reviewing phones
a while ago i would buy them and hold on
to them and then sell them and i would
lose so much money in those first few
years on youtube i was like net loss
every year all the time because i'd buy
like a samsung phone for like 700 pounds
and then they don't hold their value so
i'd sell it for like 250 like four
months later i'd be like what am i doing
to myself
yeah yeah
well like kind of pivoting to desk
setups a little bit because i do want to
talk about that because
they're all related in the end at the
end of the day but i know that my my
audience loves talking about death set
us but like in your perspective like
what what do you think is the key to
building an awesome death setup we
talked a little bit about like you know
to you it's really important to like
bring the individuality and figure out
what you like and stuff like that but
for anybody who's like let's say we're
like starting from scratch
um they have some sort of budget to like
build a desk set up like what do you
think
are the things that they should think
about i don't know if it's your
gadget recommendations or just like
mentalities and perspectives
my biggest one and everyone's pretty
gonna roll their eyes at this but it
does make the biggest difference is to
just tidy up like actually have like a
proper tidy of your space and like
and
and really like set out where you want
it to go like grab a piece of paper and
sketch out the room and just have a
genuine thing what do you want to see
when you walk in there like what what
what's the first thing you want to see
you want to see a bunch of art on the
wall do you want to see like a nice
pegboard like the one i've got behind me
do you want to see like you know your
computer sitting there ready to go sort
of thing oh my god
[Laughter]
so so have a think about that but the
the i think the main thing is is don't
don't just look at um like
stuff that you can just get off the
shelf like um a lot of the best desk set
up so like the one i'm not saying mine's
the best by the way but like one one
from ikea you know you can build it out
of certain parts like my one's like a
kitchen table top sitting on a drawer
that's sitting on a trestle so it's not
it's not like people ask like where'd
you get your desk from it's like it's
made from bits of from ikea
um
but yeah i i think
try not to fall like fall into you can
fall into a trap of like making it like
a the gray white and black sort of
aesthetic but you yeah i think you the
the best desk setups i think are the
ones that have so much personality is
like wow what does this person do how do
they how do they make their money and
it's like you go in there and you get
such a sense of who they are because
they've got like such cool stuff on the
wall or like
they've got maybe a switch rather than
like a ps5 or like a
rgb gaming setup or they've got like a
bunch of art books you know things that
mean a lot i think um
matthew and cena's setups are incredible
i think he's so good
yeah they're stunning he's he's got it
like on lock he knows exactly what he's
going for and it whenever i see his like
updates i'm like oh my gosh like let me
watch it immediately totally and he's
like i love that he's so like bold in
his design designs too where it's like
it's not just like let me make this
small upgrade he's like i'm going to
install this custom cabinetry on this
side of the wall because that's what i
want i
the kind of courage and the boldness
that you have to know what you want and
to do it is like incredible because like
i think the way that i've started
thinking about death setups is like it
is kind of like the cross between
like a pragmatic like very useful like
workstation with interior design at the
end of the day it's a form of
self-expression it's like it but it also
has to be useful like you have to find a
chair that you can cut sit comfortably
on but it also can look nice
um you can have a color palette you can
have artwork you can have
whatever
beefy like gadgets and setups and stuff
like that it has to work i originally
started off like desktops where i was
just like it just has to work like it
has to be mvp like
like i just need it to be functional i
guess yeah but then as soon as you get
over the functional part and you're just
like okay actually in reality the thing
that you need to make a dust out of
functional is a computer a desk and a
chair probably yeah and then you know as
your needs grow you can get more things
but then like if you can then get past
that and just like okay let's not make
it just functional but let's also make
it beautiful is when like things get
really cool
absolutely i i think it's like it's
really good to like if you've got like a
guilty pleasure or something like it's i
don't know maybe it's anime or maybe
it's like a really specific video game
is like inject that in into the setup
but just very kind of like i always
think not over the top so maybe you just
have like i've just got one amiibo on
the show i've got a lot of amoeba i
don't want to admit how many i've got
it's embarrassing but i only ever show
one because it's like well the interest
is clearly there but i'm not like and
here's my setup of every character from
animal crossing it's like no no no one
needs to see that but they might need to
see like tom nook sitting on the side
and that's that's enough right right
right yeah cause i'm looking look at him
you should be like oh he plays animal
crossing and that's that's all the
signal that you need that's all you need
you almost like don't need to mention it
it's like you know sometimes when i'm
talking about like the link uh one i use
a lot i'll just slide it into frame and
i won't say anything it's just there
yeah so it's like oh they kind of get it
and also like i think it's
i think it's okay to not not like some
setups like some people think i think
they think like the rgb thing is like
the go-to or like the the super clinical
stuff is a go-to
it's fine to stand back and go like
because i like some of not the rgb stuff
but i like some of those things but it's
like i wouldn't do that but i really
really appreciate it and it's okay to do
that just take little bits from those
things so maybe you like the cleanness
of it so i'm gonna wipe down my desk
every day or something you know
something like that right totally for me
it's neon signs where i'm just like i
love the look that it brings to a room
and i really appreciate it and there's
some really cool artwork um and like
colors and stuff but i would likely
never put it in my room but like the
thing that i like about it is the way
that it lights up a room
they're so beautiful
they're so pretty yeah yeah but like i
can appreciate it but i'm like and
literally i've come so close sometimes i
was like maybe you shouldn't get me on
the side uh
i think sarah dietschy has got like a
peach one and it's so cool and when i
saw that i was just like oh my god like
i need one but then i
i must have fallen into the same trap
because i was like the thing is when you
turn that on neon signs are bright like
that's going to go like
over everything you do
so it's um you've got to be okay with
the look so i guess like if you were if
you were to kind of like make like a
three-step plan for like making a desk
set up like would you start with like a
sketch of your desk area first to figure
out like what you want it to look like
definitely i've always i've always
sketched out like before what i want so
um matthews you know again is like a
really good example but here's a like
cad drawings and stuff but honestly just
grab a bit of paper or whatever you've
got and just like really roughly sketch
out the room and just like yeah that's
the first step is i'd draw kind of what
i want and then i guess step two is i
try and get the main pieces so try and
get the desk and try and you know you
don't need the best thing straight off
the bat i think ikea you can build an
ikea desk setup for like
i honestly think about 40 to 50 pounds
because you can buy like pretty cheap
legs and you can buy the classic white
table tops like 11 pounds which is like
i don't know 16 or something which is
cheap you know it's quite yeah so you
can get there you know talking of cheap
things like putting art on the wall is
probably one of the cheapest things you
can do especially if you print it
locally and it makes such a massive
difference and then um step three is i
would say so i'm i'm jumping on the
steps
step three is just to iterate as you go
like it's not i don't ever consider my
desktop done it's never done there's
always things i'm adding like i've had a
desk shelf on here for a while i'm
considering taking that away at the
moment and maybe putting something else
there
so it's like that constant iteration but
yeah well just it's
now we're all working from home and
stuff it's like i want to sit in a place
that i really love
like i don't want to sit in like a
horrible like i see a lot of people
working from home and sitting at the
kitchen table and if that's what you've
got and that's fine but i'm like no no
no
i want to sit somewhere awesome all day
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally and if it is
the kitchen table then like spruce up a
kitchen table or something like that
there's there's so many i think there's
a way to work with everything like right
like no matter what space big or small
i'm actually really inspired by like the
small space interior designers because
it's just they're so clever with storage
and the way they decorate and stuff like
that but like there are going to be
limitations and that's totally fine but
it's like i think when what's awesome is
when you can work with those limitations
and then still create something that's
functional and beautiful
that i feel like in and of itself is
like always worth doing it's a fun
challenge um you're problem solving your
way through it and then at the end you
can enjoy it like you get to sit there
every day really take in everything that
you want and keep changing things as you
go
leaning into like i used to say to
students a lot like i can't do this
because of that so already lean into the
fact that you can't do that or can do
that if you've got a really small room
then lean into the fact that it's a
small room and look at like things that
you can potentially fold up and move
around and put stuff on the like you can
hang your chair on the wall maybe or
maybe you've got loads of hooks so you
can do things like that like always
always lean into things that aren't
perfect and then that also makes it more
personal again and again it's great
totally i really like this um channel
called never too small on youtube yeah i
was about to mention them dude
when they when it comes up i like click
instantly
same there's okay so for those of you
who don't watch number two small is a
youtube channel that highlights small
interiors and they do it all around the
world like in italy and spain
in like south africa in the uk in the
united states and like a lot of the time
they're like renovating like a 300
square foot
um like condo or something like that an
interior designer and like they they all
they really show is like the end product
and
how they did things and they usually
interview the architect but it's so
fascinating because it's like two 300
square feet is not that big but like
they were able to fit a kitchen a
bathroom a bed a living space and a
dining space in there usually and
sometimes a workspace
and it's so fascinating
yeah i love it i love it there i think
there was one recently where they some
couple bought a uh
a place in hong kong right in the middle
like a flat thing right in the middle of
loads of others and it hadn't been
changed since the 60s or something and
they pulled it out and i had all these
like sliding doors to move from room to
room i was just like this is incredible
so cool yeah i think that yeah
definitely leading into the constraints
and like that's where like really cool
new innovative ideas can come from yeah
so you just got to work with what you
got so we're going to wrap up here but i
wanted to ask you one more thing we've
talked a lot about you know we've had a
lot of takeaways already in the show
which i love it's awesome i did i
learned a lot and uh
it's absolutely going
i guess like i i'm just curious tom what
are your like kind of favorite tools
accessories like things that you've been
using on a daily basis like just kind of
give us your fave
things like your favorites right now
because i'm just curious
i almost feel like i need to mention the
ipad because
there you go
do you know i actually i think i
mentioned this in my latest video but
the um i've been really like way too
harsh on like the keyboard the keyboard
is really good like i hated it for a
long time
just coming around to the keyboard i
like the keyboard
i've heard that a lot recently of like
yeah i feel like when it first came out
everyone's like
but then these days everyone's like yo
it's like it's actually really good yeah
it's almost it's almost like a a
no-brainer as far as other tools i'm
gonna i'm gonna mention this because i
think you'd appreciate it too but the
the new five oh nice
has been this has been great i've
actually really liked this the only
thing that sucks about it is the battery
life which i think we talked about
briefly
it's like i turned off it's got like a
white backlight which is awesome but um
it it runs it out in like
a day
which is really bad so i've turned the
light off on it now and it lasts about
two days
oh okay
but i like not having a wire on it so
it's like a i'll take that
yeah yeah yeah
it's a mechanical keyboard right
yeah yeah it's um it's like really low
profile i know if you're going to ask me
any specs i'm going to be really
disappointing and saying i'm not too
sure but it's really um i don't know if
this is oh it's really good
yeah listening um it's very thin
um it's it's like feels kind of i i
guess it feels most like an apple apple
sort of keyboard it's got that kind of
slim feel to it so i've got way too many
as i'm sure you do keyboards kicking
around and some of them are massive
they're so chunky so probably those two
there there is one more and it's um i
bought a um a fjallraven bag
which i love but yeah the this is the
game changer i bought the camera insert
for it and it's there's a camera insert
yeah and it like fills the whole thing
so it's like really massive and no joke
it's been better than my dedicated
camera bag it's no way
silly so that's that probably recently
has been my favorite thing i went on a
few shoots last week and i took it with
me i kind of took that plunge as i i'm
not taking my camera back i'm going to
take my vowel with the camera insert and
it was so much better i was like how
have they got this right
um is it do you have one of the one like
fellow ravens all open from the top
right like they don't have the side
pocket that a lot of camera bags do i do
you know i tend to find them i tend to
find on my shoes like i never do this
kind of reach thing and grab from oh
i'm usually like set up for the day so
pulling it open and stuff is fine
but yeah no it doesn't have any of that
it's very much like feather having bag
just with that insert the insert is so
cool
nice i mean
ramen bags come in much more colors and
they're a lot cuter than most
camera bags
i love them they're awesome
yeah i have the peak designs one which i
love like it's so versatile and you can
use it for so many things it's just so
heavy because it's like got all of the
the knobs and all of that stuff and i'm
just like i wish i could have something
that's a little bit lower profile still
a backpack because i also have their
like the peak design sling which i also
like using but like i'm just like not a
big person who can hold like one of
those like yeah
10 gallon backpacks on it yeah
i honestly know how you feel because
like one of the older camera bags i had
was like a big chunky boy and i was like
putting it on i was like this is this is
huge it looks ridiculous for me and like
i'm not like small like yeah if our oven
stuff has been it's great i said i was i
was gonna say i really like the peak
design stuff but it's really hard to see
it in person in the uk like they're just
not anywhere so like
i'm so particular
about certain things especially
backpacks so if i don't see it in person
i'm like
that's fair yeah you just don't know
until you like touch the quality and you
see how everything works i will say i
yeah the pete designs everyone that i've
talked to has said it's super worth it
the stitching is really good also they
have a refurbished store which is where
i bought mine
yeah so i bought my sling through that
because i was just like they don't do
sales but i don't really know if i want
to pay full price on this and they don't
really sell a lot through like merchants
or like the color that i wanted they did
i have the gray for both but they have
um a refurbished store which is really
just an ebay store that they do and so i
got it for a little bit off and i was
like okay that makes the personal
decision a little bit easier and then we
brought it on trips it's waterproof it's
like i don't know i if you have the
opportunity to try it and see they do
look great i must admit like as far as
like looking at something online goes
because i've watched loads of videos
about it and all that stuff every time
i've seen it like they do look cool they
do look great i just need to see it
right right right i've got the um i've
got the camera strap and like the cuff
yeah because i know it's going to be
great for that but um never taken the
full plunge yeah well let me know if you
ever get a chance because
i'd be curious to hear what you think
well thank you so much sean for being on
the show today where can people find you
on the internet thanks for having me
i've had a blast but um the find me at
bite review everywhere so that's bytee
and then review on twitter and instagram
and on uh youtube yeah i will link all
of those links in the show notes in the
description box down below so thank you
so much tom for being here this is
really fun
we could dive into everything and
anything
it's been great thanks so much
[Music]